hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back cuz what is this call
again seven days to die seven bucks to
rye seven butts to dry seven crabs to
cly
what are we doing with our lot welcome
back to game grumps so we're gonna play
we're gonna play seven days to die and
we could do with it
I want you oh hi oh I broke the torch
hey you scared the crap out of me in the
process sorry how do I make a pickaxe
like yours okay so go in your inventory
yeah you how many of them there's
gravity hubcaps or anything metal and uh
um a cobwebs cooking pot maybe cooking
pot I don't know you can try putting it
in the center and see if it breaks down
thinking no it didn't I got a can of dog
food if I eat that will it give me the
can you have anything like a hubcap no I
don't a just F for scrap metal you want
to go out and get some you want me to go
out no oh this all seems to be like dirt
anyway yeah so okay so basically what
you do I'll tell you how to do it I ate
the dog food
I'm just I'm just telling you now okay
well thank you the dog food yeah what I
don't know if you can make it you might
be able make a shovel I'm gonna put some
scrap metal in here okay in the duffel
bag all right okay seven scrap metal how
much do I need for this well it takes
three scrap metal to make one iron ingot
you put them across the mitt you put one
in the middle and one on either side oh
I see okay so if I make three iron ingot
3-hour ingots might be enough for a
shovel is it should I think of this like
Minecraft yes well sort of they don't
they don't line up the same way but if
you have the stuff in your inventory
then the let the word will appear as to
what you can build so if it says shovel
on the right side you can click on it
and get a pattern uh I don't see shovel
aishi sledgehammer and hunting knife
fire axe that sort of stuff mmm here a
fire axe is useful I've never had one Oh
hmm you want me to get that because mozz
well you might as well come on save it
I'll just be punching furiously let's go
dig what do you want mine you can show
off mining a little bit
okay I'll mine yours there you go whoa
that that is something terrifying yeah
let's go in the mine by the way if you
find a femur a bone put it in your
inventory and it breaks down into a
knife I got pushy um nitrate what do I
do with that someone's looking bullets
Oh Oh should we be worried what the
sounds we should always be worried it
was that something broke
what road something broke I heard
something break oh okay oh okay let's
just go downstairs let's just keep
digging
ah that's I know I know I should be
worried yeah yeah see this is that good
we're gonna die I won't worry about all
this what go ahead and mine I got this
do do you I mean thanks I guess I'll
just keep going yeah they're killing
each Ono that killed a deer
how am I gonna be able to see when I get
down here porches do you have any I
don't you know I don't I don't have
anything here I'll throw it down
I'm actually really I'm actually kind of
nervous seriously they're panic inducing
there's torches up here you can pick up
I threw him on the ground above you okay
man how do you have all this stuff and I
don't I don't know I was collecting
stuff too but you just got the good
stuff that's what it pays to be Lord of
all minions ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha do
you call your family that's your minion
at all you can build yourself a thingy
oh I already have a thingy
thank you for your self I use it a
useful one oh but rolling my thing like
railing you get scrap metal lorry
steadies you like my thingy before huh
would be good for scrap don't y'all
fight about it you're paying me need um
battle head
let's take you forever to mine by the
way besides what is down here besides
just stone ice probably check and make
sure no one's breaking through yeah
maybe I turn red ball he's here to do
that I'm coming up I'm coming up you
know what I'm coming up nope
hey I look good oh oh good ABS ready
helminth ready
Bob's ready here a little pulse Hines
seen action Bob's ready we're gonna join
us for the middle of something here
yeah you were too rare we're not gonna
stop wall behind ah did you get stuck up
there yeah I might have gotten stuck of
it oh I may have gotten a bit step over
here I can't seem to move it you are way
to fight no form a little stuck could
you give me some assistance oh man shut
up
there we go I think I'm nope no doc good
happen I just boarded this up did you
board it up on top of me never there in
the mine cuz you wanna get with Laurie
uh she was my wife oh yes I'm able to do
that I forgot about that
not that I slept with her and
banged her fugu not her what the you
know
Oh can't believe you wrap this doubt on
that point you didn't pay attention in
anatomy class with their eyeteeth up
agoos look you big you oh no not looking
- boo goo 101 - oh my bad she's subject
huh
Jesus undermining I was but I got bored
and I came up here I heard a party and I
decided to come by
what for tea you know you don't see
there's nothing sick critic in uh this
is that our problem you have a gun I
knew you had a gun I just realized I did
but wait a minute bad wait a minute she
probably won't lunch you got quiet oh
never mind
it was quiet for a little bit I stupid
teenagers breaking our house it's almost
a yet
um it's 1:00 in the morning so no how do
you know that
top left oh you mean that place where my
face is I put my webcam on the opposite
side so everyone could see that shut up
I didn't have the benefit of that so
what do we do what do we do with um well
you go mining since I gave you the
pickaxe okay I'll make sure your butt
stays alive what I mean I don't wanna
mine you want to stay up here and board
up doors go what we do wanna be with you
well I can come down then just sacrifice
oh you're playing an important role I'm
playing the menial labor role hey come
here
what come up here what take a look
why cuz I may have made an opening where
what all right what I can AB stuck again
how the torch star the torch was in my
way what's up what's up oh hey that's hi
hey how's it going
Oh baby where-where-where
got sort of a followed on having a
copyright cuz were enjoying our fine
night enjoying our fine night living our
lives we don't want to mention to the
max at all like the girly chocolate
thing you know the girly shop you think
no no I don't know what girly line the
line that I can't sing like ah then
break you through I'm beating them with
my stick but it don't seem to work oh
it's working so uh you want to go out
there and a blaze of glory
nothing good will come of that you want
to go if you kill them they just respawn
while I go out there and Oh blaze of
glory hey I got some pills out of them
all right one drink of water huh
all right you got this right yeah you
got this going to mind and mine up some
ayran know already have some fun is
there is it possible to like smelt and
stuff like in Minecraft I yeah I think
so right now if you find that stuff just
put it in the middle of your inventory
it automatically breaks down oh cool
wait there is no smelting device or
something yeah I don't think they've
added that feature in yet okay like I
don't know how diverse the crafting
system actually is cuz I don't know at
first I wish it was but I think it's
going to get there I hope so I mean it
is still an alpha and we're still kind
of like it's a fun game but still trying
to see if the price is worth it
yeah gotta get the best to the audience
cuz if they got to see what they're
gonna get I gotta be willing to shell
them I am oh okay releasing customizable
maps and like randomized maps will be a
lot better yeah cuz then they get with
this Abbas Abbas boom yeah and
I don't know I'm talking about a boy
I've not known for a while we tossed a
weight ah I found more saltpeter hey we
have a problem
I found Peters salt he lost it down this
mine who's Larry oh good
wait did you laugh at my joke I couldn't
because two zombies got in ours
potassium nitrate not saltpeter my
mistake well I really imagine what your
joke doesn't based on the bed you'd
better result Peter you know Peter saw
any ladies for his corn-on-the-cob job
why what no one gives an ass whether you
ever gives one because they probably
died I don't think you'd die if you lost
your ass I don't really know against a
bit much of it you lost there appear to
be zombies in the middle of our living
room happened up here um explosion
situation killer wall yeah what about it
I did not watch it and well looks like
the park at this place and it huh well
I'm gonna make a fire axe probably a
good idea because this gun sucks oh you
got to make it diagonally that's not a
fire axe oh maybe you got it oh I see I
got it okay I got a fire axe what do I
do with it
um well in the morning there'll be lots
of zombies to go outside and kill I
already hear lots of zombies what do I
do about it
we wait till morning because you don't
want to be cutting down the front door
gasps dummy or would it kill on the wood
that idea that I highly discourage I'm
gonna go hello oh there's wood this well
that is loud noises what uh-huh so
saying hi this Thursday
Oh going over there I'm killing
sometimes are you doing good I'm just
making sure that's all you're doing
I'm killing loves up oh I'm doing yeah
potentially in our lives at risk well I
would never by the way
funniest thing ever that you've ever
said that after you put the pumpkin in
the crotch you remember that your app I
didn't even remember it until I watched
the footage again and I saw it was I
stared laughing I couldn't stop it's
funny anyway um Wade uh Wade what I'm
going for
you can't Sammy I'm gonna kill them all
ha got one
good luck thank you what you can't be
many I'm getting the water in the table
getting all these goodies Wow this I got
him you wish you and me you wish you
were me I'm living the life that you
wish you didn't have such a bad idea
shut up we're going we need to make it
to the grass
alright we're going north on north baby
let's go run for it
how do we I can't see you want torch
here how do I give it to you just hold
it
yeah no take it please I got the ax I
need to kill him okay we're gonna kill
it
Oh see it's moving yeah try to eat my
baby hold still where'd you go you dead
you put the porch away you didn't let me
kill it man you didn't trust me you got
trust me Rick
oh you swinging a fire axe in the dark
well so pretty my face is not something
I've generally trustworthy about never
heard Hey look another missing segment
of this map I don't see anything what
are you talking about I don't see
anything either that's my point
clever very good with that one Hey look
a deer want to blam it what is it doing
what is that deer doing mistiness ah
it's coming at us
like
you didn't let you let the nurse get to
me I have to eat my foods almost all the
way gone
my foods almost all the way gone yeah
baby yeah what's this honey how is it
Hey how shut up you shut up you shut up
- shut up well somehow it weird on Elena
what is it what day I have no idea
okay okay so we made it we survived we
did we did we survived the night
provides a night in a really crappy
house yeah you did you guys think that
we would do it I didn't cuz vows with
wait I mean come on you're not survived
even one night yet no I hadn't I died a
lot it's really day we really did it I
can't believe it the attics and
buildings and some of these houses are
really good for surviving for a little
while - oh yeah hello dog dog I got hi
Fido whoa jeez a little pent-up anger
much let's check one of these houses we
got a few minutes left
oh look someone boarded it up with check
mailboxes - really that doesn't make any
sense
oh I don't trust you on that one
sometimes there's paper and scrap mono I
think you're a liar dirty
why did oh you can actually board this
up I guess yeah you can because someone
told me you can make boards like that I
still remember how there must be like a
list online of stuff that you can make
and I'm like all there is seven days
today I don't know if they made it or
somebody else made but there is a
Wikipedia that has some of the recipes
oh I mean I'm sure there would there's
gotta be a there's a pretty decent
community building up around I mean I
look at this server it's a pretty
popular game considering it's not even
fully made I mean considering the
Kickstarter was still popular I think
behind us yeah uh I see huh what's up
here besides death cloth for torture
I'll let you have grant metal what is it
ganja case oh good I didn't kind of a
gun I feel like the fire X is pretty
nice the virus is like really nice like
no joke not even lying why would I lie
to you why do you think I've lying to
you
I didn't say anything what do you say
what I've said nothing yet you don't
trust me you don't you did try to kill
me in the woods
did I Weiss I wonder how that turned out
nobody knows cuz nobody's gonna say
anything great nope nope nobody say
anything
what'd he say anything about what may or
may not have happened in summer I'm come
on
you killed that corpse you did it good
oh that's you oh my god I still heard it
growling did I scare you Karia wait you
did you're sure I'm a scary monster
other puppy Gert here we're we're all
right there I got it hey let me at it oh
you guys you didn't even need me
beautiful man
you do in the daytime they're easier to
kill alone won't you swinging ah it's a
pukey Cobb Wow we're one here oh my god
they puke if they're like a special mom
yeah I got it Wow Wow
oh you've exploded got a little
something on your chin there thank you
I know I've been trying to grow my beard
for a while this cop sucked because if
you fill up a nice bass and one of them
comes by it takes like two pukes they've
broken in good god that sucks like you
sold out so I agree that does suck the
finest guys that that is indeed a lot Oh
what what okay dog a dog I love like
whenever I'm separated I still hear
somebody like freaking out attacking
something did you get what I like
we've done a lot of behind-the-scenes
stuff with zombie he's always stays
pretty calm right yeah there's an
episode that I recorded yeah where JP
gets glitched out of like are safe
basement area that we'd built and zombie
and died and JP was supposed to be
letting him back in and JP glitched out
and zombie just like a freaked out I'd
love to hear zombie free cuz I think
that's like Episode four of my second
playthrough of this but it was awesome
interesting anyway my inventory is
almost full with stuff like seriously
some yeah that's one you can store
things like in the suitcases if you find
a space that you want to stay at yeah
unfortunately one of the downsides of
this game right now is that there's a
lot of stuff you want to hang on to and
you do run out of space pretty fast okay
and I'm trying to sort my inventory
because I'm trying to break down any
like blue candy tins that you have yeah
yeah I have a bunch of those that's
right the Rick all that stuff down in
the scrap metal candy tins and a scrap
metal god break out into stone you pick
up a crawl you could break them into
stone and stone blocks or sturdier than
wood okay all right got it alright
actually we are just about out of time
for this episode so we're making some
good progress guys we're really doing
something good here so not bad not bad
work Wade we're surviving we're
survivors yeah we could make it another
night in this house this is a good house
for with this attic here yeah cool
alright anyway so thank you all so much
for watching applaud our efforts because
we're not doing do badass 5 deny it's
routed I yes do anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always we will see you
ah
gruffly again
nice non bones
oh now
people shouldn't be watching this
I'm not oh
watch